thanks for joining is a city bookshop
thanks for joining us at ISA T bookshop
who's here for the first time welcome
thanks for stopping by we're really
excited to have you for tonight's event
and just so you know what we do have one
to two author events every single week
plus our weekly book clubs to story
times per week and a variety of social
gatherings like coloring books and wines
so if you enjoy your time here tonight
please do check us out on social media
that's East City bookshop on Facebook
and Instagram and East City books on
Twitter and sign up for our newsletter
and you'll hear about all of the other
cool things we have coming up but
tonight it's our pleasure to welcome
Doug Wead Doug is a New York Times
bestselling author he has been an
adviser to two American presidents and
is one of the few living historians to
have written about all of the American
presidents he has interviewed six US
presidents seven first ladies
co-authored a book with one has
entertained two in his own home and has
served on the White House staff as a
special assistant to the president he
co-founded the charity Awards with First
Lady Nancy Reagan and he is here to talk
about his new book game of thorns with
Kenneth Walsh whom he'll introduced
shortly after our talk we'll have a Q&A
from the audience and then you are
welcome to purchase a copy of the book
to have signed at the back so thanks
very much for joining us thank you very
much Hannah it's my privilege to
introduce Walsh he he was the president
of the White House press corps
association that they put on the big
dinner that Donald Trump refused to
attend this year one of the most
prestigious events in Washington DC and
he has covered how many presidents can I
six presidents in the White House as a
part of the White House press corps he's
worked at US news for how many years are
33 years 33 years and senior writer he
said almost every title and position you
can think of it US News he is a
remarkable journalist he may be among
its they're almost extinct I'll put it
to you that way he may be around among
four or five journalists that I know of
who I don't know where he stands
politically all the others I could tell
you if they're left or right I can't
tell you where ken is because he is
absolutely objective and pursues the
story whatever it may be so I guess we
could call him a traditional journalists
or old-fashioned journalists but it's
it's it's a profession that's
disappearing pretty quickly and only had
a brief time where it flourished so I'm
gonna turn it over to him he's the
author of many books in his own right
one that I loved is a history of all the
places where the presidents lived like
Nixon and San Clemente and the Kennedys
in Hyannisport he's written a book on
that which you can find here in this
bookstore and he's another book that I
love is the celebrity president he
writes about how presidents have become
celebrities and that's part of their
power today the extension of the bully
pulpit and he's got a new book out I'm
gonna ask him to at least say what that
is and then we'll get started okay thank
you as Doug said I'm a traditional
journalist so I hope that by the end of
this discussion you don't know my
politics and I'm glad I've succeeded in
that for 31 years of covering the White
House because I don't think I could have
covered presidents ranging from Ronald
Reagan to Clinton Barack Obama to both
bushes and now Donald Trump unless I
could sort of taste that talk about
things right down the middle but the
other thing I want to mention is that
Doug and I have known each other for
worse about 25 27 years now and so I
hope that we can conduct our talk here
like we we
talk over lunch that we're going to be
sort of informal we welcome you to ask
him questions afterward and I find that
whenever we have lunch and I do this
with many sources the best information
comes in a more informal give-and-take
which is that what I hope we will do so
with that I you know we're in a very
interesting time for for Doug's book to
come out and but he mentioned he's kind
enough to mention that I have a book
coming out called ultimate insiders it's
about White House photographers who are
the staff photographers the personal
photographers is the presence where the
ultimate flies on the wall here things
that no one else hears see things that
no one else sees and so that's my next
book coming out in September but it's an
interesting time for for this discussion
and for Doug's book game of thorns
because the town is just the biggest
parlor game here in Washington now is
what is Donald Trump all about what is
he going to do next what is going to
happen what's the Republican Party mean
anymore and I hope Doug can explain a
little bit of that as we go on where the
Democrats go now what's become of
clintonism and so on but really it's
Donald Trump who's sort of dominated the
day to day and with his tweets the
overnight because in every news
organization we basically have to have
somebody cover Donald Trump from 11:00
p.m. to 4:00 a.m. because he puts the
tweets out then so there's another layer
of coverage that's been added but I
wanted to start by asking Doug basically
just the basic question which you talked
about in the book at great length
what did Donald Trump do right and what
did Hillary Clinton do wrong and what
what just jumps to you to the top of
your mind as to how this election turned
out so many people were wrong so many
pundits were wrong so many people in my
profession were wrong people both
parties were wrong what happened yeah
yeah I I rattled off numbers that she
out staffed in five to one outspent him
eight to one if you count soft money and
Trump did have a super PAC that got
started Eric beech and Edie Rollins and
Jesse Benton got something going but
raised 32 million she her super PAC
raised more money than any super PAC in
American history and they spent it all
she she had a ground game with nine
hundred and sixty thousand volunteers on
the ground and it exceeded Barack
Obama's ground game she had Eric Schmidt
she had the CEO of Google in charge of
social media
she had a Hollywood she had academia she
had Wall Street she had the banks she
had 240 newspaper endorsements he had 19
but he had a message and the message was
burned like a brand it just everybody in
America knew what his message was
everybody in America didn't know if you
asked them right now what is Hillary's
message but they knew Donald Trump's
message make America great again and
we're gonna get jobs back and when I
would say to them at Trump Tower you're
off the message what was this stupid
tweet about
they'd say no we're on message because
part of the message is he's not a
politician and I think the American
people were tired of politicians they
had the last two presidents the rich got
richer the poor got poorer some would
argue and felt that free enterprise was
dead that you had to be an insider
they sawed his corruption both on the
left and the right and here was somebody
I firaon eclis a billionaire but a
troublemaker and they wanted to see
everything upset so in a in a funny way
his off message quaint mistakes were
reassurance to them that this guy's not
talking a book about the Hillary
advantage of the Clinton advantage what
was that and it really wasn't an
advantage in the end was it no it wasn't
an advantage she had the advantage of
experience she had all these things
going for her but there was some hubris
obviously and
yeah yeah well is on me because I was
out covering the rallies and for both
sides really and I remember people
in Washington saying the other rallies
are intense there are giant crowds for
Trump and so on far outnumbering Hillary
Clinton's rallies in numbers and
intensity but it really doesn't tell you
how the election is going to come out
and Trump said the rallies do matter but
and it turned out that they did and I
wonder if you saw that coming if you
felt that intensity around the country a
lot of people also said if they went to
these places in these Rust Belt states
like Pennsylvania and Ohio and some
extent Wisconsin they saw all the Trump
signs hardly saw any signs for Hillary
Clinton and in Washington it was
dismissed all people just put signs up
but that doesn't indicate what's going
to happen on Election Day
I wonder when you saw it coming that
Trump was going to win yourself well I
had Bob Potter here who by the way he's
going to have a book the next book party
he was telling me there Trump signs all
over Pennsylvania I was in boy don't see
him and the thing that I kept thinking
of Ken was I remember George McGovern he
had very intense rallies and I can't I
can't forget George McGovern saying well
I don't believe these polls I see the
enthusiasm of these crowds you can't
tell me this doesn't equate to something
so I kept hearing that echo in my mind
when I'd hear Trump say oh these rallies
there may I kept remembering George
McGovern who was misled by those rallies
in the impact of those rallies but I
have to admit that it took me off guard
I'm portrayed on YouTube is one of the
few that said that he might win I could
see you know it's been a specialty of
mine the evangelical vote and my family
I have to say my wife Miriam of thank
her because she was running everything
while I was working on this book and my
daughter Chloe who's around here
somewhere
taking pictures they were helping me do
the research on the book but one of the
things we hit on was the of angelical
vote and they just missed it and Barack
Obama saw that and he called up there
towards the end and he said you are
losing the white evangelical vote and
you don't have to and they laughed at
him and after the election was over
one of Obama's assistants wrote an op-ed
in The Washington Post that said why did
Hillary lose the evangelical vote part
of the headline was she didn't ask for
it
well that turned out to matter because
81% of them voted for Donald Trump and I
can tell you from our experience they
were very conflicted right up to the end
he was lewd he was not someone they
wanted to support but when on November
4th when a bunch of celebrities got
together and they started using the
f-word and all kinds of profanity and
saying get out to vote F and this F in
that using Jesus and I thought wait a
second what would you would what a bunch
of celebrities to get together and use
the name Muhammad as a curse word in a
campaign song what kind of reaction
would you get well 1% of the American
population or Muslim 70% are Christian
is that going to work
so nobody you know on the flyover state
from East Coast West Coast they don't
pay any attention to this it doesn't
matter but it does matter in those
flyover States but I mean Trump did not
have the role model qualities he was not
he didn't live his life as evangelicals
and conservative Christians or
practicing Catholics feel that someone
should live they lived their life as far
as sort of the studio 54 hedonistic
lifestyle and how he talked about women
and so on how did people get past that
he knew some of the buzzwords you admit
there's a moment in the book game of
thorns where he's in Trump Tower and
he's real depressed and he's despondent
and he misses this old preacher norman
vincent peale
which is who was a presbyterian very
positive guy on Fifth Avenue he would go
down to his church listen to him he
missed him so he's watching TV and he
sees this sexy blonde televangelists
come on and she's talking about hope but
he calls her up on the phone he says
gosh you're terrific
can I get you up here and he flies her
up to New York City and she walks him
through the neighborhood so to speak
because when you study Donald Trump's
life he would always move into a
neighborhood and rent he wouldn't buy
and he'd rent and then he'd hit the
pavement he'd walk around and he'd
listen to people and he'd talked to
people he wouldn't buy a thing sometimes
for several years and then when he
thought he knew the area he'd buy well
holla white this televangelist she
walked him around the evangelical
neighbor he knew the the different
subcultures you know when you talk about
26% of the American population and you
compare that to African Americans 12.9%
there's a lot of subgroups he understood
those and when he gave his speeches and
he he'd say things it would be little
hints that they'd pick up on that would
go over the heads of the Washington Post
the New York Times at one point he says
to Paula Jones
this is sinner Donald Trump you should
know I've been married three times and
she says me too
so she wasn't judgmental to him so they
were kind of soul mates oh that's a
story that has hardly been told it's in
game of thorns and then the Catholic
story was there's a story in game of
thorns where Bill Clinton takes his
telephone cell phone and he throws it
off the roof of his presidential pad in
Little Rock Arkansas cause he's so mad
and Hillary and the staff he wanted her
to go to Notre Dame and st. Patrick's
Day to give a speech she wouldn't do it
and then when the Podesta emails came
out you can blame it on Russia but when
they came out what was in it the
Catholic spring that was damaging and
Bill Clinton's answer was you need to
get out in front of that you need to
speak up and basically the Catholic
spring idea was once we get into power
we're going to set up and these
committees and we'll co-op the Catholic
Church and will influence their doctrine
to make it what a Catholic spring well
more of a liberal more of little more
socially acceptable a lot of bishops or
thinking way it's one thing for you to
separate church and state and get mad at
us for talking about social policy but
you're gonna take over our church well
Bill Clinton wanted her to get
front of that say look we're not gonna
do that this is wrong this is a Miss I
denounce that I just like a Republican
would denounce a donation from the wrong
person but her fear was there's no
reason to call attention to this a lot
of people don't even know about it let's
what the news media is not covering it
so let's keep it under wraps and Bill
Clinton was saying you can't do that you
gotta you it's out there it's going from
Bishop to Bishop from diocese to diocese
you got to get out front say absolutely
not nope we had nothing to do with this
well that I mean you mentioned that some
of us came out in that email and let me
interrupt you say 22% of the population
or Catholic right but and and this was
part of that email sort of leaked of
massive amounts of email from from the
Clinton campaign if I'm from Podesta who
was the campaign chairman John Podesta
and Jennifer Palmieri was part of that
who was a communications director both
of whom were Catholic as I remember this
yes but which was why they had the
expertise to feel they could influence
right so how much was that the the leaks
how much difference did that make
I think they were big because the
Catholic vote if you'll think back if
you'll remember when George HW Bush won
he won with a tremendous landslide and
he split the Catholic vote 50/50 with
two caucus and yet he won a landslide
because of the percent of evangelicals
he had right well Trump he took the
Catholic vote substantially over Hillary
Clinton she could have gotten a portion
of that as Barack Obama said afterwards
if if she'd asked and as Bill Clinton
felt if she'd had gone after them so she
could have had some of those so I think
those leaked emails did have a big
impact and I think the Clintons that
belatedly came to that conclusion I
think their first reaction was this is
all Jim Comey's fault and they said that
that was an interesting release that's
in public statements it's all Jim
Comey's fault and then later you don't
hear him talking about Jim Comey anymore
then it became the Russians fault in
fairness
in fairness the Russians gave money to
Hillary Clinton they didn't give any
money to Trump they gave money to her
foundation right and they got the
Silicon Valley deal they got the uranium
deal there was actually potentially
theoretically an exchange there was no
exchange with Trump that if they helped
Trump okay he's in power the first thing
he does is increase military spending
what kind of deal is that for Russia
well I think I wanted you to talk about
a little bit doug is the white
working-class because I know in the book
you talk about how you picked this up
and I was picking it up from a reporter
standpoint on how no we couldn't was
just completely missing the problem she
was having in these Rust Belt states
they were confident they were going to
win Pennsylvania I mean that their their
litany was always the Republicans always
talked about winning Pennsylvania but
they almost never do don't ever do they
they did oh hi I didn't expect at this
time right and and of course Florida
different area of the country but what
happened with the working class I know
in the book you have I actually put a
little tag on it here because I Percy
come from a working-class background
myself and I know you said people who
had been overlooked despised stomped on
used taken for granted this is their
moment to speak they had been shamed
into telling the pollsters what they
wanted to hear but in the privacy of
their polling booths they had struck a
blow talked a little bit about that how
did Trump see he's not a working-class
guy he's he's an American a business
aristocrat how did he sense this yeah
and and and Michael Moore was right on
the money when Michael Moore did his
event in Ohio he would kind of tease the
audience if you remember that he looked
out at the audience and he said I know
what you're gonna do and they all kind
of laughed like like he caught them like
they were little kids
and he caught them in the act cuz he
knew they were gonna vote for Donald
Trump
I think they resented being pushed and
they resented the the media the
condescension of the media this is how
we want you to vote I think the media
some
the media may have overplayed it and
they just reacted to that don't tell me
what to do a little bit it might have
worked but I think it might have been
overdone the media came off as a little
desperate they did during the Reagan
years and and they didn't like being
called racist they had voted twice for
Barack Obama the same group all through
those Rust Belt states they had they
took great pride in the fact especially
the catfight Catholic Union voters twice
they had voted for Barack Obama they
were proud of themselves they love to
see that that stigma of racism ended and
they took pleasure in voting for Barack
Obama now they were being called a
racist because they didn't vote for for
another Democrat who wasn't African
American I think they thought no I'm not
gonna be pushed into that I don't need a
job the deplorable moment talk about
that a little bit where Hillary Clinton
used that word you know to describe a
lot of the Trump supporters and that was
taking us a really offensive by a lot of
people well and it was worn like a badge
by many people because I guess it shows
the humor again of it was overplayed so
people said oh you know we're quick to
think of the worst thing about ourselves
if somebody says something about us and
it's critical we very often will say oh
that's true and we'll assume but here
the voters were just defiant like I'm
deplorable give me a break they thought
that's overreach and they kind of pushed
back and took pride right and wore
deplorable on their on their lapel I
wanted to get to serve more what'd you
make of what's going on
contemporaneously here with President
Trump but before I do that what did you
learn about the country from this
campaign yourself what did you learn
about where the country is politically
what the country wants from its
government how much of a change do
people really want and what did you
learn about Donald Trump well I would
love to hear your answer to that
question well Sarah falter and I have
talked about that a lot she's Seraph
you'll wave she's
hache yet and works for Hesh yet the
publishing company who were terrific
by the way they turned this book around
on a dime I don't know how they did it
they're pretty very impressive to me but
what I took away is that the American
electorate were they were onto things
that I I I couldn't believe they were on
to and in some cases it was almost
instinctive they didn't know how the
import-export Bank works the average
person doesn't know how the Federal
Reserve works didn't know the details of
the stimulus plan which allowed though
it was pushed by liberals and it was
Obama's plan it allowed major companies
to virtually ignore environmental
regulations so they had in both ways
they could say we're strong on the
environment and they could let major
monopolies disregard the environmental
laws but keep them for small businesses
so there was a lot of I don't know how
else to put it but corruption and that's
why towards the end
Steve Manon and pushed Trump into this
drain the swamp because the average
voter out there they couldn't explain
what the details were but they had this
innate sense we're getting screwed and
they had it on the left the Bernie
Sanders people they called us by
oligarchs you had it on the right with
Ron Paul people who had come out of the
woodwork in 2012 and the lack of
response to Romney when Romney came
forward I think he was a bit shocked
that people didn't say right he thought
this is gonna be easy I'll just step in
here so I came away impressed with the
fact the average person out there
they've got a good sense of smell and
and they sense something's wrong and
that's why they're picking trunk yeah
well see I I just in the column about
this for US news but I think in
Washington we tend to make the mistake
of seeing things just from the political
prism but if you look at polling our
institutions are in big trouble with
people as far as credibility goes like
example like organized religion
the church as people see it Congress the
news media the presidency the presidency
has gone from a 73% favorable rating in
people's minds in 1973 to about 20%
today or 30% Congress is like 9% the
only institutions that are above water
in other words have a favorable rating
are the military and the police interest
just about everything else is as a
tremendous credibility problem or crisis
and so I think that Muslims what you're
saying I think people sense something is
sort of gone gone wrong here
and for many years that famous polling
question of its the country and headed
in the right direction or on the wrong
track has been in the negative that
people feel were headed in the wrong
direction and I think people just got to
the point where they said Donald Trump
is a flawed candidate he's a flawed
messenger but he's going to shake things
up and I think that's to me that's one
big lesson I drew from the whole
campaign but but I wanted to ask you a
little bit now about where we are today
Donald Trump has talked about doing
things that Republicans have
traditionally liked such as increasing
the military budget as you said
increasing the homeland security budget
just came out in his budget now but at
the same time and he's cutting social
programs but at the same time he's
opposed to free trade that Republicans
have liked for many years he doesn't
want to tamper with Social Security and
Medicare which a lot of Republicans want
to find ways to overhaul so what does
the Republican Party stand for anymore
and what does what does what is trumpism
what does it mean I think we're going to
transition right now and and the it
hasn't settled it hasn't been determined
but I think we're where we've been cut
loose and we're adrift right now but it
seems like the old left and right no
longer applies yeah but there there is a
sense by some that the United States is
like Congo it's like Brazil everything's
up for sale I think part this is my
opinion I think part of the
genomic boom on Wall Street is what I
describe as Yellin envy and by that I
mean that yes I get alone from
indirectly through my bank or maybe
directly from the Federal Reserve but I
don't need it I would do better in the
free market and I don't get a big as
loan as you do and so there's a sense
that yes there's corruption but I don't
know that I'm getting the best deal in
this corruption I may be beating the
small businessmen but I don't know that
I'm beating this big company over here
and almost a desire to end it I lien it
for me let's end it for everybody let's
get back to who makes the best product
and comes in on time right and and
serves the marketplace and I think there
was excitement that maybe Trump can find
a way back to that right so that isn't
left or right right that's kind of a
recapturing free-enterprise I think
we've lost a lot of it since 9/11 under
two presidents a Republican and a
Democrat president lost a lot of what to
free enterprise and well that of course
Donald Trump's signature book was the
art of the deal and in that he talks
about lots of his his approaches to
doing things and of course in the
campaign he builds himself as the deal
maker who will get a lot of better deals
for the country and just about every way
how much can his business savvy
translate into governing now because we
haven't really had a good experience
with business presidents in the past
I mean Herbert Hoover was a pariah you
know in our history for a long time he
was a business man but he did have some
government experience too can trump
convert his business prowess into an
effective governing strategy I think I
I'd give him some credit for some of the
jobs that have come back some people say
well you know that's just talk that's
but that's part of the process of being
the leader is the talk is to say it and
to try to get companies to please him by
bringing jobs back what I like is the
whole China thing I think he he was wise
enough to
we've had Ken the largest transfer of
wealth in him in world history outside
of the Middle East and that's been the
wealth that has left the United States
and gone to China in 2015 the trade
deficit was 367 billion dollars but that
doesn't begin to account year after year
after year the money that we borrow from
China to do the things that we want to
do and it's paid off with they
manipulate their currency so they pay
off their debts with cheap dollars and
Trump's the first guy to talk about it
and the last three presidencies Clinton
Bush and Obama the last three
presidencies
have really greased the skids for China
there's no way under normal
circumstances China would ever have been
allowed in the WTO without the Clintons
paving the way and that was at a time
when China was giving huge amounts of
money to the DNC to the Clintons there
was a scandal FBI started to arrest
people they fled to China and they had
to give it back they had to refund the
money most people have kind of forgotten
ignored that in the book game of thorns
I show that [ __ ] lapsing one of the men
who wired a million dollars into a
restaurant owner in Little Rock Arkansas
and he showed up again on the streets of
Manhattan the FBI arrested him and we
don't know the outcome of that they
found suitcases full of cash in his room
so there's this one scene in the book
where Donald Trump's with Melania and
she is saying to him why did you do you
have to do this we've worked so hard and
we finally have this great life and we
have reached this moment where
everything's perfect why do you want to
do this and he senses that it's being
taken away from him by Melania and he
says in the past tense he says but I
could have been so good I could have
done such a good job it's like he can't
be President
and and it was China he's thinking I
know what to do I know what's going on
and I know how to fix this and I could
fix it I have no strings attached
I'm willing to take this on nobody else
is and then at that point
Melania says well if you want to do this
then you have to do this but she warns
him you'll wind it she wanted to make
sure he understood you're not just going
to increase your market share buddy if
you'd if you go for this you'd be
prepared for the fact that you're gonna
win this there was always this chatter
in the pond autocracy more or less that
he really didn't want to win that he
just wanted to increase his brand he
wanted to be more famous that he would
just sort of take even the sense he
would take his marbles and go home and
he would give up the nomination or
something but you found that at the end
of the campaign he was working a lot
harder than Hillary Clinton he was had a
lot more events and he really wanted
this he did and there's a part in the
book game of thorns there's a part where
he's prepared if he loses there was talk
in the green room at Fox that will start
our own television network will write a
book called rig didn't we'll have a
website in a landing page and we'll have
Sean Hannity come over and be on our
television network with Sean Hannity
says no no I never and he did he never
agreed to that but that was a talk and
so he was prepared for that but Reince
Priebus and others to use this axiom and
I used it as a title Sara falter knows
in the book that was you got to land the
plane and they say that a pilot if if
you're in trouble if you lose if you run
out of fuel if you if both engines are
blown and you're gonna die and you're up
there the the a pilot is taught you do
not stop flying the plane you fly it all
the way down to the ground
maybe you'll die but you're definitely
gonna die if you panic so you keep
flying that plane you look for a field
or a highway somewhere to land it you
watch for the telephone poles you watch
for the high wires the trees all you
don't stop until you're on the ground or
you're dead like the fellow who landed
in the Hudson River like the fellow who
landed in the Hudson River and that's
kind of like a Trump metaphor for so
according to Reince Priebus he went out
there he started building the ground
even though everybody said it was too
late he knew you can't win without a
ground game so when he started about
three months out there was one field
office in Florida Hillary had 57 and
they had already completed most of their
work he had won but he kept building
them and by the time of Election Day he
had a 87 field offices in Florida they
barely squeaked out Florida
if Reince Priebus hadn't done that they
wouldn't have won so at a certain point
you're right they they out worked
Hillary and it came at the end and
Wright said that on one interview on TV
he said I'd rather I'd rather in the
campaign like this with the wind at my
back right who's now that she was staff
at the White House Ryan's but what is
what do you make also of the the
willingness to take out after his
opponents to sort of the scorched earth
policy if someone criticizes them he
doesn't he has to respond to the slights
and so on and particularly this
accusation that President Obama spied on
him at Trump Tower warded wiretapping
and without any explanation what do you
make of that yeah I I don't like it and
you know I wouldn't advise it if I was
working in the White House or on his
team but as I've said it's kind of a
quaint reassurance to people who like
the fact that he's got these rough edges
and he's unpredictable and he's not a
politician because they just hate
politicians but having said that I have
to tell you something Donald Trump's not
the first president to suspect that his
predecessor spied on him when the
Clintons came into power Hillary Clinton
you can read about in game of thorns she
was absolutely convinced that dear old
sweet George Herbert Walker Bush was
spying on them so he had been director
of the CIA so she had the Secret Service
sweep the private apartments of the
White House and wasn't satisfied had the
FBI come in looking for bugs to see who
was listening in the previous president
and eventually the Clintons organized
what they called the White House
security
personnel office and they put two of
their own campaign staffers to run that
to access all the old files of their
political enemies and my file because
they had all of George Herbert Walker
Bush as files brought to them those are
the ones J Edgar Hoover used to use for
blackmail purposes and the Clintons had
access to those it became a scandal it
was called filegate so Trump's not the
first president to think that I forgive
him from do for doing it I mean this is
this is this is this is a case of one
president calling his predecessor
without evidence publicly I don't think
the Clintons made that public that it
didn't get done well you're right that
Bush was spying on him you're right now
they did oh they were very obsessed with
the idea that the White House household
staff and the eff and the Secret Service
we're not loyal to ya and you remember
all that because yeah the fan there's
truth to that they were right right
right they were right but but but the
Trump the trunk defenders would say he's
airing it out it's good to air it out
and it may be that it's good to talk
about it because after the news media
said to us all this guy's not easy
saying his predecessor was wiretapping
only a few days later their big story is
by the way the CIA can look at you
through your samsung television set so
which story is true you know maybe it's
a good thing to talk about okay but I
mean I'm I don't think we're on the same
wavelength on this particular there's
there's a an expectation that a
president might have a more elevated
respect for evidence and public
disclosure but in any case but the other
thing in in looking at Trump today is
how much can he unify the country is is
he seems to be focused on this idea of
the of this sort of state that's buried
in the government to to work against him
the bureaucracy is against him Obama
holdovers or against him
do you take that very seriously and can
he bring the country together I think he
can I mean we saw an example of with
that speech
if if if he'd kept if that had kept
going if he did kept doing that I think
he could have do I think he will I don't
know and I do believe I know everybody's
everybody has said that they said it all
through the nomination process then
through the general election that there
is a point where his missteps could
reach critical mass and he could leave
lose his base there could I saw it
happen with Richard Nixon I I remember
with Richard Nixon people would say well
if there's one more thing than I and
then there was one more thing yeah they
say well I'm still with him but if
there's one more thing and they kept
doing that and then finally they reached
a point where they said okay
that's it but there's been a lot of one
more things with the prom fight there is
retained the base there is - and there
was with Nixon but it if I did
eventually reach critical have a sense
that it would be like just a snap
judgment type of a thing or start a
change of policies or broken promise or
do we really have much of a sense of how
that might well I don't have a sense of
it because everything is so scrambled
because of the sense of the people and I
think rightly so that there's a lot of
corruption yeah and because of that I
don't know that they're willing to trust
somebody else and they do I think they
do resent being pushed like their
stories on TV about how much money it
costs to for to protect the Trump
children what do they want they want the
Trump children to be murdered I've
traveled with the children of presidents
around the world and they have to have
Secret Service protection so here they
are on TV they look at all these money
they're spending to protect the Trump
children where they do they want Malia
and Sasha to be protected that they want
Chelsea to be protected why would they
not want you know they want them
kidnapped or murdered or something of
course not do they want them held
captive at Camp David you know so they
aren't spending money so I think people
kind of resent that and then
was a story you correct me I'd like to
know because I keep seeing online
different accounts there was a story
that Trump was giving back his salary or
trying to find a way to give back to
salary if that's true then for a news
agency to run a story saying look at all
this money he's wasted he just flew down
to Mar larga and not to add by the way
he's not taking a salary yeah I think
that omission I think is kind of
irritating to people in the audience
like hey well there's a lot of reports
who tried to get the White House to
explain where that stands as he started
to give his salary back and they refused
to answer the question so we don't know
we're told we don't know we don't know
and then of course during the campaign
Trump made a big thing about Obama
playing golf all the time and traveling
to around the country on vacations and
he's doing it more than Obama did yeah
and a pro-rated basis so there's a lot
of by the way would you tell the story
or will I get you in trouble if you
would tell the story about George W Bush
who was elected as the new president he
flies from Texas back to Washington and
the only people on the plane this great
big plane is empty Karl Rove and you and
I don't know who else if anybody and you
sit down with the new president-elect or
president I think was President Elect
and he asked you about well I know
there's a number of ways that story
could go
I think we're conflating a number of
stories but I know there was one story I
maybe this is one you're thinking I
ranch I had three days at the time in
the ranch well he well there was a lot
of stories about the ranch too but the
one I think that is sort of relevant
here is how blunt he was in many ways
because I remember when I first was
getting to know him before he ran for
president he was governor of Texas and I
had known him when he was his father's
troubleshooter as you remember yeah
because she worked with him then too and
I went down to Austin and was in the
office with him and Karen Hughes who was
his spokesman a spokeswoman left the
room it was just me and him and he was
showing his baseball collection which
I'm sure you've seen I gave him his
Mickey Mantle 50
Wow that's that's a big sacrifice that
was but he never said thank you both
sitting there by ourselves and he said
you know I hope that now that I'm he was
had been elected I'm president that you
and your colleagues in the media giving
me a fresh start because I know it's
different I used to be what he called a
fierce warrior from my father
now I'm president I know there are
different roles that might be a little
residence there with Trump as the
campaigner and the president and so I
took a risk and I said just him and me
and he knows I tell this story mr.
president in those days you're pretty
much of an [ __ ] and he said well
you're right I was forgive me for my
language that's the way the story went
and he was very much saying just give me
a chance I'll show you I can do things
better and a lot of people did give him
a chance particularly after 9/11 but in
person he was a much different guy than
he came across in public he was a much
as you know he was a much more engaging
interesting guy but he and also he did
go to his ranch a lot and he just said
it's my ranch and I remember traveling
around there with him and he was driving
his pickup truck and I noticed these
flames he was burning cedar which he
felt was an invasive vegetation I said
what are all these flames all over the
smoke all over the property he said well
I'm burning the cedar and I said well
isn't that against the environmental
regulations he said it's my property and
I'm gonna do whatever I want on it but
the story I wanted you to tell and I
hope I don't get you along this guy's
maybe I'm spacing this out what's
something to the effect when you got on
the plane he asked you how many days did
Reagan spend on the ranch you know I
don't remember where that story goes as
I remember I know how many days it was
you you young you gave some kind of
answer 60 days he was relieved because
he was going back to Washington and he
already couldn't wait to get out for
sure
that's right he couldn't but no he
because he he went to he exceeded that I
think he was
his rants 400 some days but Reagan was
at his ranch for almost a year out of
his eight-year presidency but he did pay
attention you're right so people are
already measuring Trump Oh is going to
morale are go too much but I thought
that was interesting exactly and I've
got a George W Bush story that relates
to issues today and that is when Donald
Trump said that he thought his
predecessor Obama was wiretapping him
right Obama's statement release
statement was the president never
directed that Donald Trump be wiretap as
soon as I heard that I thought ooh
because presidents don't direct I mean
that's a thousand years old that's henry
ii will no one rid me from this
meddlesome priest because henry ii and
the legend in the story was just
astonished that his entourage couldn't
figure out he wanted that man murdered
and finally he said will no one rid me
of this meddlesome priest and they race
off and they butcher thomas becket and i
remember a time being on the airplane
with george w bush where I said to him
I'm gonna do this this this this this
what I was going to do wasn't illegal
and he kind of grunted and moaned mmm
and I took that to mean okay that's what
he wants me to do and I did it and it
turned out afterwards he was happy
that's what he wanted me to do but I
thought back on it many times he never
said yep that's it that's what I want
you to do so heads of networks heads of
bookstores heads of magazines of mafia
leaders on the street presidents the
United States they don't direct you I
want you to bug Donald Trump's apartment
but you quickly figure out what they
want sometimes they're silent and
they're telling you what they want well
there's also this notion of the
plausible deniability
you remember that phrase from the Nixon
em seriously well you don't want the
president to know certain things so the
president wants to have a way of denying
that he ever knew about it but I know
you don't open your mouth in front of it
right and then you're exempt was a very
good
but then there's also this whole FISA of
this foreign intelligence court system
which operates independent of the
presidencies orders so there's a way
that could have happened at surveillance
too but I suspect what we're hearing a
lot more about that as as time goes on
here but but I think you know the do you
see signs that that Trump is thinking
that he has to sort of temper himself or
do you think he just doesn't feel that
that's necessary and well my baby wants
to do I'm seeing him quiet now he's been
like on the network news they say it's
five days he hasn't answered this when I
see that I think Hillary Clinton who
took 300 days before she had her second
press conference but five and Counting
that he hasn't responded so they're
trying to build a little suspense that
come on and that's great if he's gone
five days or seven days yeah good for
him well do you you haven't been in the
White House yourself do you think this
idea of the disarray that's been
reported and talked about is overdone
what do you think there is some some
disarray or was that pretty normal for
this pretty normal I remember with us
with George Herbert Walker Bush it was
John Tower who was supposed to be the
cabinet he was supposed to be the
Secretary of Defense and this was so
comical and the US Senate was outraged
and we got to wide this up the US Senate
was outraged and they said no he can't
be
Secretary of Defense he's an alcoholic
well for the US Senate to cuff to
criticize somebody for being alcoholic
it's just the dad bit hypocritical he
did he didn't make it he was he didn't
make it but as you say we've got you the
sign here that we have to move along so
for anybody has some questions or
however you want to have and also if our
live-streaming had a cook anybody on
livestream netic question Chloe and
anybody else a question or comment you
may have a comment you wish to make
ciara which US president would you like
in Donald Trump to the most and could
you explore some of the similarities and
differences the one I compare him to
most too is Andrew Jackson because the
first six American presidents were
Episcopalian and here came and had to be
if this tell you to be president and
here came Andrew Jackson who was a
Presbyterian like Donald Trump and they
were all six presidents were East Coast
he was West all six presidents were part
of the political aristocracy forum were
Secretary of State two of them came from
the same family John Adams John Quincy
Adams they all favored the National Bank
which Andrew Jackson said is just making
the rich richer and the poor poor and
they wanted a second National Bank he
said absolutely not he was profane he
was crude he had bullets in his body
from duels and from battles that he had
fought as a general when he came back
after he won the election they made the
White House turned into a wreck it was
like a drunken party he had to sneak out
go to hotel to spend his first night in
the White House so I compared him and
then he took revenge after he won he
appointed all the positions to his
buddies and to business people instead
of the political elite who wanted those
positions the spoils system it became
known as the spoils system and it became
a it became a scandal to eventually but
that was Andrew Jackson so I keep
comparing to him some comparing maybe to
Teddy Roosevelt only to the extent he
seems to be willing to bust up some of
the corporations that he feels have an
unfair monopoly see I was in Jackson as
well for the reasons Doug said but for
another couple of reasons one is that
there's the temperament comparison the
anger that he felt he wanted to show
anger on behalf of what he didn't use
this phrase but he felt they were
forgotten Americans then that Trump
feels are around now and he was
representing them and they really
a lot of Americans really felt that to
their core that they were not being
represented during the campaign one of
the reasons he was such a tough guy when
he was president is because his wife
Rachel he married her and she was not
divorced from her first husband because
she didn't he was a very abusive she
didn't realize the divorce had not gone
through so his opponents in the campaign
made her seem made out to be an
adulteress she didn't realize this was
going on they kept her protected from
this and she found out about it and she
died before he took office of a nervous
breakdown and he always blamed his
adversaries for killing his wife that's
pretty that's a pretty harsh way to
start your presidency and when he took
over that he was so angry that he was
very very aggressive against his
adversaries and the other interesting
comparison is that he set up his own pro
Jackson media which is what Trump is
doing with with his going to the
alt-right media and Breitbart and these
other organizations and and Jackson was
the forerunner of that he he would
actually have his favorite newspaper
editor this was a partisan press at the
time to the White House and he would
dictate stories to them
I'm sure Trump would like to do that
himself which he actually does on
Twitter anyway so technology has changed
but there are a lot of a lot of
comparisons there very good any book
about about the high tech technology
that Hillary had and that basically the
Republicans had none of that is that
what does that say for the technology
and then what does that say for if the
Republicans did get organized with
technology what could happen Wow
Thomas Sullivan he's got all the
attorneys in the world you want to well
I mean when Reince Priebus was head of
the Republican National Committee he
said that Sean Spicer who's now the
White House back at Eric's press
secretary was his chief strategist said
they were going to have technology that
was comparable to the Democrats that
they had they had caught them now it
turned out that
they had not but it turned out also that
the technology we were fighting we were
looking at fighting the last election
Trump had other ways of dealing with the
country and he didn't use the old
technology micro-targeting and so on
which the Democrats relied on and did
very well it's just that they missed the
boat in the seven key states where
micro-targeting didn't didn't get to
them to the resemblance that we've been
talking about in the Rust Belt states
and in Florida and some other places but
I think that one thing I think we might
have learned from this election is that
we can overdo this idea that technology
political technology is the be-all and
end-all I think that we have to
reevaluate that in addition to polling
we have to reevaluate how much credence
we put in the polls because the polls
took a big hit I must say that the
pollsters did pretty much get the
national vote right Hillary did did win
three million more votes than he did
largely because of California in New
York but she did come close to what the
pollster said the national margin would
be but electorally that's where the
pollsters were automatic in those seven
key states and if you do your own if you
do your own search go go home and put
into Google and start searching some of
the issues you'll see how Google slanted
pretty dramatically compared it get into
a search engine like Yahoo or Bing or
Internet Explorer any other search
engine and compare them and you'll see
the power of of taking control of the
search engine the Clintons were able to
take control of the Google search engine
so you could type in for example if you
do right now if you type in Hillary
Clinton CRI if you do it in being our on
Internet Explorer it'll automatically
finish Hillary Clinton crime Hillary
Clinton crime family Hillary Clinton
crimes if you do it on Google's say
Hillary Clinton cries and the second one
will be Hillary Clinton criminal justice
reform speech
we'll be the second choice if you go to
the Google searches and you print out
what is searching on Google you won't
find you won't find hardly anybody's
searching Hillary Clinton criminal
reform criminal speech you won't find a
very tiny percentage of people but it's
up there is a very second search so in
the area of Wikipedia she did a great
job and they really dominated Wikipedia
and in the area of Google searches with
the help of the former CEO all of Google
they did a tremendous job so the
Republicans have a lot of work to do
still
technologically during the research for
the book I know you met with a lot of
your resources and did you come across
some stories that you wanted to put in
the book but you just couldn't you know
validates now it's your turn to get it
stories that well you wanted them in
there but you couldn't validate the
story or you tried to get it in there
but maybe editing took it out well the
the editor Sarah can speak to this
better than me but the editors at ha
shet were very thorough the attorney we
spent almost a week going over where'd
you get this who was it what and their
attorneys would say so there were
occasionally some not good enough but
most of them we had multiple stories
like for example the story of Hillary
when she learned that she lost the
election and when it dawned on her that
it's probably gonna slip away that I
didn't want to put that in when it first
came out cuz it it seemed like voyeurism
I wasn't sure it was true then the
second source said no you know
shattering glass screams profanity anger
tears and so there was all of this going
on and the second source wasn't good
enough but after three sources I said
you know this is a part of history and
somebody else is going to write it and
I you know I can't control what happened
and what didn't happen and so I wrote it
and then when ed rendell the governor of
Pennsylvania appears on national TV says
I just left the peninsular hotel I went
back and saw that in some of the
youtubes and she's very angry and yadi
dah I thought well but yeah there were
some stories like I was troubled by the
source who worked for her for almost 20
years who who said that I thought this
was troubling to me and that her Secret
Service agent the the woman assigned to
protect her life referred to hit her as
first as Barbara Bush would say which
but it reminds it rhymes with which that
was what she called her and when I heard
that I said the person you're kidding me
said no I said what do you think when
you heard that I thought it was very
disrespectful I was astounded that you
know this person is gonna die take a
bullet for her and why but he said after
I worked there for a while I realized
she had a very mercurial personality and
there were people who could react that
way so there were some stories that
didn't get in but not too many we went
with what was there and there's the
story of Johnny hyung who has we don't
know where he is so he made this
videotape said if anything happens to
him or he disappears
he made this videotape and he made it
for his lawyer and for about 14 people
one of our researchers got it we have it
and he's lives in the People's Republic
of China and he's disappeared but he was
the only of 140 witnesses in China gate
he was the only one that actually
testified before Congress and told what
he had done and what happened and that
the money did indeed come from the
People's Republic of China and I'll say
this after the book was published I got
a phone call from a whistleblower who
said I I've read some of the stories
about your book I've ordered your book
and I have a story that I think can now
be told and so he told me his story and
I've hooked
up with the FBI I I said the FBI may not
be interested in this it may be old
history but they may have some loose
ends that they want to finish up and so
they're looking into it this involved
the transfer of welding equipment that
allows the silkworm missiles to work the
Chinese had developed missiles and they
weren't working they were blowing up on
the launch pads and they were missing a
key part and that transfer was made
during the Clinton administration at the
behest of officials from the State
Department who asked who said that your
United States government would
appreciate it if you would fill this
order for this company from Harbin China
so that's an interesting that's a
potential news story and like the
Kennedys and FDR we're just now learning
what some of the things that went on
there are things were still going to
learn for years to come about some of
these presidencies so the short answers
yes but not much I put everything I
could put in the book I did anybody
online that says do you believe with how
brazen he is that Trump has the
potential to push back on the political
correct culture which is making it
increasingly difficult for conservatives
to stand up for their conservative even
biblical convictions yeah I think he has
I don't know what your answer would be
to that but I think he's very
politically incorrect and you know I
think he has pushed back a lot and you
know the other point of it is that a lot
of conservatives are emboldened to speak
more freely and and they have their own
in our fragmented media culture this
there's many more outlets for
conservatives to be heard now than there
have been in my lifetime the same for
liberals really we're just broken into
compartments and we talk to each other
in our own little political worlds
and don't talk to people beyond them and
I think that's a big problem for the
country and but I think conservatives
are very much emboldened to to speak
their minds as our liberals it's just
that they're talking over everybody else
both sides and I think that's
unfortunate that anger is really
disappointing ya to see that and when
you when you live in other countries and
you travel in other countries and you
look back on America they're so close
and when you get here they seem so far
apart and they're so angry it reminds me
family some of the worst acrimony can
happen in families among cousins or
siblings or the closer they are the more
intense the rivalry can be and that's
how I kind of see it here but it's
unfortunate I think I wish Mark Romero
were here tonight because he helped with
the book game of thorns and he did us a
marvelous study on the media and he
tracked every moderator of every
presidential debate
there were 126 of them I think and
because of the internet there was no
mystery now he could clearly identify
liberal or conservative a hundred and
twenty one of them starting with Howard
K Smith they would say something in a
speech and you could find it online and
identify themselves very clearly you
remain a mystery but they were over they
were overwhelmingly like a hundred and
twenty one out of a hundred and twenty
five were Liberal Democrats well the
other thing about these debates and I'm
interested in your view about this is if
you look at that key debate the Kennedy
Nixon debate in 1960 work the people who
watched it thought Kennedy when people
heard on the radio thought Nixon won if
you look at the role of the moderator
which was Howard Kate Smith he was
sitting in the back they had a panel of
reporters who weren't even facing the
camera then the candidates were
absolutely at the center of this when
they introduced the reporters they had
to Crane their necks to turn around and
say I'm sander van ochre and very
awkward but now the moderators are equal
to the candidates there they probably
have as much time as the candidates do
and I think that's a troubling thing but
but that
another way it's changed the political
part of it is one part but the other is
just the celebrity culture that the
moderators think that they are as
important as the candidates are and the
first debates like lincoln-douglas those
debates there were no moderators right
there was a clock they just spoke for
one hour an hour and a half and the next
one got to speak right exactly yeah but
no interest so much different and you
know and I think there's going to be
some changes next time around but I
think the country also gets to the point
where they feel is probably too many of
these debates but it was quite a show
but but part of it is that's like I say
the celebrity culture just it's just
part of what we are as a nation ID in
game of thorns I deal a lot with the
debates and the the the poison of megyn
kelly do you know that story she was on
her way to bathe in the coffee yeah she
gets in the she gets in the limo and and
the limo driver offers megyn kelly some
coffee no no no I don't need anything so
please please you'll feel better no no I
don't want anything so they go a little
bit further and he says please you'll
this will relax you you'll be okay so
she takes the coffee and she immediately
gets violently sick she gets into a
bathroom and she starts throwing up and
so she covers up with a blanket that was
the debate where she says to Donald
Trump you call women fat pigs and if
that was the question that came out she
had a blanket underneath the desk to
cover her up and felt like she'd already
caught the flu or was she poisoned so
very very interesting and having worked
in political campaigns anything is
possible
that's right well but you remember that
in when bushed your President Bush who
you work for and was running against
Dukakis in the debate Roger Ailes later
head of Fox he realized Bush was nervous
so just before the debate started he
made a big a moment of walking out on
the stage just as the red light was
supposed to go
on the camera to Congress is looking
what's going on here and he handles Bush
hands Bush a piece of paper and Bush
looks at it smiles and and on the word
was on the papers to where it kill but
it just relax Bush he was sorta not a
jokey boat but Dukakis was thinking what
is this some kind of a secret ambush
that's going on here
but sometimes the advisers just have to
use those techniques to to get the best
out of the camp one of the stories and
games of forms was the collusion between
the Clintons and the bushes early on
they had they both had the same donors
if you look through the list of donors
the major donors the major donors were
identical and early on the Clintons sent
the signal to the bushes don't worry
about Donald Trump your boys gonna be
okay meaning Jeb Bush because there's a
silver bullet out there and it's gonna
take Donald Trump out of the campaign
I don't determine in the book whether
the silver bullet was the the British
Secret Service file or if it was the
Access Hollywood file because there's a
whole nother part in there where NBC's
troubled over how to release the the
Access Hollywood file and win but
because Billy Bush a relative was
involved most people assumed it was that
so right away the Jeb Bush campaign is
relieved and they begin looking for the
silver bullet oh this is obviously going
to be something will be easy to find
because the Clintons are telling us
about it and so they start looking for
it and I was a part of a presidential
campaign with George HW Bush and his
opposition research was something to
behold you punched the buttons in in
that office on 14th Street you went into
this lab earn if and here were dozens
and dozens of people in little cubby
holes and it was pre pre-internet than
the stacks of National Geographic and
life magazines and camcorders following
every candidate everywhere they went you
just it's hard to imagine how much money
they spent on opposition research so jeb
Bush's opposition research in this day
of intelligence officers and and bugs
couldn't find it so finally as they got
closer to the nomination jeb Bush's
people one person in particular
approaches
the Clinton people and says no what was
that you were trying to tell us
they're asking help you give us are we
getting warmer they needed a little hit
and by that time the Clinton campaign is
saying no way if you can't find it
you're on your own because they thought
this guy is gonna win Trump's gonna win
the nomination we're gonna face him in
the general and we'll save that silver
bullet for then yeah well you know the
other is as you well know the the Bush
family they believe in sort of a certain
nobility in public life but they need a
tough person around them the master of
negativity and Lee Atwater was the
father's man he pioneered a lot of these
negative campaign techniques and and if
you're interested Lee water that water
is a fabulous story on how he reinvented
politics in many ways by focusing on the
negative and he was the guy behind that
whole they could find somehow whatever
they needed to he knew how to do that
sort of thing huh and then the Sun Bush
the Sun had well of course Bush the
father also had Roger Ailes it was no no
pushover
yeah pushover either and then Bush
George W had Karl Rove he was another
tough father and the father had Jennifer
Fitzgerald for a while and dick darman
was our know who's the other guy well
Janu know he had he had synonym of
course but then before he went in he had
I can't remember his name now that's
what happens when you get gray hair but
you're right he always had somebody
tough there who could be the stalking
horse so he could be the right the the
diplomat which he was but now it's so
it's it's is so [ __ ] and we've had
negative campaigns and now Trump was the
lee atwater naturally he says only how
did that's a very good point exactly
yeah so anyway Thank You Hannah and
thank you for joining us tonight it's
been a pleasure to host your talk please
feel free to remain for a little bit get
a book have it signed mingle with the
authors and thanks for visiting a city
bookshop thank you very much
see why do you like you can see why we
like to have lunch and talk so yeah